Iran and Pakistan are heavily armed
neighbors with a history of tense
relations which escalated earlier this
month after thean launched a missile
strike on a site inside
Pakistan 2 Days Later Pakistan
retaliated by launching an attack of its
own inside
Iran the crossb violence has been the
worst in recent years and raise alarm
about a potential wider instability in
the region especially given the war on
Gaza Pakistan recalled its ambassador
from Teran after the attack but soon
after intense diplomatic efforts East
tensions and they agree to return their
ambassadors to the respective capitals
but many have been questioning the
reason behind Iran's attack Iran
basically wanted to pacify its internal
uh pressure from the people at the same
time Iran struck in Syria in Iraq and
Pakistan it wanted to give a strong
message to its people that uh it is
capable to protect or to uh to take
revenge a top Iranian revolutionary
Guard general was killed in a suspected
Israeli strike in Syria in December and
earlier this month isil took
responsibility for an attack that killed
more than 90 people in the Iranian city
of kman in response Iran attacked a Bas
in aril in Northern Iraq on January 15th
saying it was a spy center run by
Israel's Secret Service mosad before
striking the Pakistani group a day later
Iranian foreign minister has gone to
Pakistan to restore damaged ties his
spokesperson has a positive message for
Islamabad I want to repeat that the
relations between Iran and Pakistan are
strong friendly and brotherly the two
countries agree on respecting
sovereignty and territorial
Integrity Iran and Pakistan are facing
significant security and economic
challenges for the time being both sides
say they want to avoid further
Priyanka Gupta
Al make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer